Completely gorgeous.
>> Wow. What the You carry them with
you?
>> that somewhere, you'd go, "Okay, aliens
have been here." Yeah, yeah, exactly. If
you didn't know. That's how advanced
Muslims were and Muslim woman was
serving the dean. They did this? Yes, a
Muslim woman in hijab.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them?
The Quran. Why? Because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets. Brothers and sisters, imagine
you have a app, the Qurani app, which
not only shows you how much rewards you
get, but reminds you to read the Quran.
Gives you reminders. Download the Qurani
app now and let it testify for you on
Yawm al-Qiyamah that you read it
wherever you was. Maryam al-Asturlabi,
have you guys heard of her? I'm sure you
haven't and the Western world would not
be talking about her because it would
debunk all their claims that we Muslims
are barbarians. Brothers and sisters,
what I'm going to show you is going to
blow your mind. Before that, brothers
and sisters, don't forget to like, share
and subscribe to the channel, brothers
and sisters, and share this video far
and wide because this is what they are
hiding from us of our history, brothers
and sisters. A Muslim woman who learned
from her father and her surname, we know
Asturlabi, yes, uh
referring to astronomy. Subhan Allah,
she is the first woman that came out
with this long, long before the
Westerners did Subhan Allah who woke up
to this navigation system that they are
using to today on Google satellite,
brothers and sisters, and the navigation
software that they using with satellite,
it all goes back to the methods that she
used. Before we do that, brothers and
sisters, let's go to the video,
inshallah. Okay, who was Maryam
al-Asturlabi? She was born in Aleppo in
9 944 CE and she invented this
uh device called an astrolabe. Subhan
Allah. And, brothers and sisters, what
did that do? Obviously, for the Muslims,
it was important when it comes to prayer
times, direction of the qibla, the
latitude, the um the the track of the
stars, compass, guiding ships and people
and it's a navigation system, brothers
and sisters. Subhan Allah and wait, if
you see it, Subhan Allah, and see the
reaction of Joe Rogan, you'll be
mind-blown. Now, to make something like
this, you had to know astronomy,
mathematics, metalwork and engineering,
brothers and sisters, Subhan Allah. So,
imagine a young Muslim woman learning
from her father, Subhan Allah, where
these people would talk about all the
first Muslim woman being oppressed, etc.
This is what the Muslim woman were doing
1,000 years ago that we use today. Every
time you use GPS,
every time you check your location,
every time you navigate anywhere,
you're using a principle perfected by a
Muslim woman.
Her name was Maryam al-Asturlabiya and
in 944 CE, she was building the most
advanced navigation instruments in the
world.
Born in Aleppo, Syria, Maryam was a
master maker of astrolabes.
The astrolabe was not just a tool, it
was the GPS of the medieval world. It
told the time, it measured latitude, it
tracked the stars, it guided travelers
and ships across vast distances.
To build one, you needed astronomy,
mathematics, metalwork and engineering.
Maryam mastered them all.
Her instruments were not only precise,
they were beautiful.
Geometric patterns, elegant Arabic
calligraphy, detailed maps of the
heavens.
Each piece took months and she signed
every one.
While many women elsewhere were denied
education, Maryam was teaching
navigation.
While others were kept from work, she
was running her own workshop.
Today, when your phone shows your
location, when satellites guide your
journey, you are using the same
principles she helped perfect.
The astrolabe became the sextant, the
sextant became modern navigation.
But the mathematics, the star
calculations, the foundation still
traces back to her.
Her name, Maryam al-Asturlabiya.
Her legacy, navigation for the modern
world.
Her recognition, almost none.
It's time the world knew the woman who
helped humanity find its way. Let's go
to the video now of Joe Rogan absolutely
being mind-blown. He's like, "Yo, wow.
Really, wow." And Neil deGrasse is
actually even educates
Joe Rogan. He says, "This is not
something you were taught in school."
Let's watch for ourselves, inshallah.
So, you learned deep scientific
knowledge about how far away the planets
are and how far away the sun is from the
earth. It was not known with precision
before that measurement was made. So,
Captain Cook goes on this voyage to do
this. Well, this is a pretty expensive
voyage.
Oh, oh, wait, flip over the marching
orders. Oh.
Open the envelope. Oh, while you're
there, use these new navigation
techniques that use the sun, moon and
stars and map every coastline you find
and bring that information back to us.
Within 10 years of Captain Cook
navigating the South Pacific as well as
the northern coast of of Australia and
New Zealand, within 10 years, Britain
took control over those coastlines.
That's interesting cuz it shows you they
were using astronomy and these
navigational systems to take over lands,
you know, and the Ottoman Empires and
the Ottoman Empire uses and the Muslim
world uses to their advantage as well.
Let's carry on. Became part of the
British Empire.
Hegemony at its finest. On the premise
that he's observing something about the
universe,
but there was a tandem role that he
played. I did not know they knew that
much about the cycles of the planets
that they could be there. They knew
accurately that they could be in the
>> Wait, just wait till Joe Rogan hears.
He's He's talking about Captain Cook or
Hook, whatever his name is. Okay. He's
like, "Yo, I didn't think they would
know that." My friend, let's go hundreds
of years before her, a Muslim woman,
Maryam. What did she come Look at how
mind-blown Joe Rogan gets, inshallah,
cuz he's he's shocked about, you know,
what Captain Cook is doing, okay? Subhan
Allah, forget that. Look Look what was
Maryam was doing. Motivation,
part of the motivation of knowing any of
this was navigation around the globe. It
was navigation. How you going to know
where you are on earth? You can get your
latitude. That's just the altitude, the
height of Polaris, the North Star above
the horizon. You measure that at night,
you can wait that long. Where do you
know where you are
in longitude? Ships would would be
shipwrecked. Millions of dollars worth
of commerce would be at the bottom of
the ocean because they didn't know where
a coastline was. The only way you can
measure coastline is if you have good
navigational tools and tactics, which
involves an accurate chronometer, a
timekeeping device for your and knowing
what the sun, moon and stars are doing
in your sky. So, the astro Subhan Allah,
look how glorified Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala is. Those stars, the sun,
they they served us. They served us,
Subhan Allah. If you look at it, it's
like everything, the creatures,
everything is there to serve us.
Alhamdulillah. And look how Subhan Allah
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala is great. And
not only that, Neil deGrasse was going
to mention that in in a minute as well,
that 2/3 of stars have Arabic names.
Because the Muslims look because of
Muslims.
in that day was crucial to the mapping
of the earth. And who's mapping earth?
Is it just geologists for fun? No, it is
nations uh wielding power
over regions beyond the beyond their own
coastlines.
And that's why I have a quote here.
That's where this quote comes from. I
got a guy from 17 Where did I get it?
1757, James Ferguson.
1757, here's his quote. Of all the
sciences cultivated by mankind,
astronomy is acknowledged to be and
undoubtedly is the most sublime, the
most interesting and the most useful.
For by knowledge derived from this
science, not only the bulk of the earth
is discovered,
but our very faculties are enlarged with
the grandeur of the ideas it conveys,
our minds exalted above their low,
contracted prejudices.
>> Woah. I could drop a mic on that. Here
you go. Boom. Drop that mic. Look at the
statement, it's so profound what he
said, Subhan Allah, like the this
individual who he just quoted, the the
importance of astronomy. And who's
behind that? Maryam al-Asturlabi who
learned from her father, Subhan Allah.
Now, just wait till it gets to now the
Islamic sciences and the inventions of
this amazing navigation device. So,
[laughter]
notice he lists mapping the earth first.
Then he talks about how it exalts in in
our grandeur. Mhm. So, uh yeah, it's an
exercise in dominance, in hegemony, in
power under the guise of studying
Well, it's not so much that it's just
they call they they they they married to
one another. Yeah. I'm part of it. It's
part of it. And they're using a sextant
for all this? So, sextant helped, there
was an octant a little earlier.
The
the the Muslims used an astrolabe. Okay,
you've got By the way,
uh what's the number? It's a third or
two It's about I forgot the fraction.
Around a half of all stars that have
names in the night sky have Arabic
names.
>> Now, this is here where Joe Rogan is
mind-blown. He's like, "Yo, how did the
Muslims come into this conversation? You
know, we're talking about the Western
civilization and the Golden Age,
whatever." He's like, "How does this
Muslims play a role in this?" Watch
this. This is this This is the truth
that they've been hiding from us, guys.
This is why it's so important for you
guys to share this video far and wide.
Because in the Golden Age of Islam 1,000
years ago, navigation was a big deal and
they navigated using astrolabes, which
is sort of the the the Islamic
counterpart to the sextant and the
octant that were used in the rest of
Europe. Astrolabes are gorgeous. Oh,
they're they're they're works of art.
They're brass, they're etched.
>> Bro, I love it, but look at Joe Rogan.
He's totally He's like,
"What is that? What is that?" Wait till
you see his reaction when he sees it.
You can buy one. You can buy You can buy
I sell them. You can buy replicas, but
you're not going to get an original one.
Let's see. Find astrolabe.
>> Yeah, yeah, astrolabe. Let's see what
that looks Oh, yeah. So, uh there's
there's a thing that hangs down. There
are different uh uh discs that you can
replace depending on where you are on
earth to be to know where you are more
accurately. So, this is all navigation.
So, it was almost like chips for a GPS
device. Yeah, so they're they're they're
gorgeous. They're completely gorgeous.
Okay, look at look at look at his
reaction. Look at Joe Rogan's reaction.
He just caught the the Watch this now.
Completely gorgeous. Wow. What the And
you carry them with you?
>> that somewhere, you'd go, "Okay, aliens
have been here." Yeah, yeah, exactly. If
you didn't Did you hear that? If you
found that somewhere, you'd think aliens
have been here. That's how advanced
Muslims were and the Muslim woman was
serving the dean. Instead of these
radical Nifaq families who are rejecting
Kuffar Kuffar. Yes, okay, they're doing
Kuffar. Allah is this, Allah is that,
Subhan Allah. Look at this. Look at the
what Muslim woman used to be like,
Subhan Allah. Look how amazed Joe Rogan
is. He's like, "Yo, if I saw that, I'd
think aliens have been here." Not only
that, one of our colleagues here,
brother Mehmet, alhamdulillah, um the he
mentioned this was so profound. David S.
Sorensen, an introduction introduction
to modern Middle East function, Kindle
edition. Okay. He said the following,
"December 1999, the American Discovery
Channel ran ran a list of 100 most
influential people of the past
millennium. While many of the great
Western scientists and thinkers were
listed, you know, whoever it is, Galileo
and Locke and Machiavelli, etc. and
Newton, for example, the presentation
mentioned that none from the Islamic
world. They are on purposefully hiding
this so they can see us Muslims cuz they
use this to show us as barbarians, you
know, when we die, it doesn't matter cuz
we have nothing to offer the world. Like
know your history. But look at that.
That is insane. That's about the size of
a um Ooh, did you catch that?
Do you see what Neil said? He said, "You
need to learn your history." Meaning
they hiding this from you. Heavyweight
uh
champions
buckle buckle buckle
>> is that thing doing? So yeah, depends on
where you are on which when you want.
That's what I'M SAYING. SO THIS is we're
talking about this was you know a
thousand years ago something I'm so
sorry. I'm flying Joe Rogan. It's like
he's been lied to so much that Muslims
are terrorists, Muslims are this,
Muslims are nothing. He's like yo, who
did I say it to bro?
Wow.
They did this? Yes. A Muslim woman in
hijab learning from her father did this
and not only that she would teach other
men. She would be teaching other men.
You know, this is 700 years ago, 600
years ago, 500 The Ottoman Empire is
spreading their influence and they've
got they've got astrolabes. So this is
Islam. You don't even learn about this
in school cuz you only hear about the
rest of Europe, Christian Europe.
So this matter
>> incredible looking device.
>> Yes. They won't teach you in school.
Yes, because why? Because the Zionists
are controlling our schools. Yes, they
they are they they are controlling our
schools. Yes, what to be taught, what to
be hidden. Yes, you don't see that you
you're not going to be told about this
in school. No way. And these are dials
that turn.
>> Looks like a tribal tattoo.
It doesn't even look like it like
there's a rhyme or reason to it with all
the claws and everything. It completely
looks like art. It looks like some
bizarre
>> like an alien yeah yeah. So Now we're
amazed by that. How amazing is the one
who gave the mind
to that woman to do that. Look how
glorified Allah is. You are amazed by
that architecture.
Go and look into a cell. Go look into a
flagellum, the tail of a bacteria which
is composed of 40 pieces like a Ferrari
engine and glorify your Lord. Again, if
you're only listening just just Google
astrolabe astrolabe and and look at any
of that's a primitive more primitive one
there. A simpler one. Um And so that's
six Now Joe Rogan's in double wow. Wow
wow. It's not even one wow. Wow wow. No,
two. So oh no, so that one that has the
spirit of an astrolabe but I don't know
that if they would have called that an
astrolabe. Um the the others they they
go way back. And so the most decorated
ones are the ones from the Middle East.
But anyhow, the point is
GPS is no different from the navigation
tools in in in concept from the tools
that Captain Cook invoked for Britain to
then take control over all the South
Pacific that they did. It is where are
we and do we know this information with
precision?
And so and what happens if an enemy
force takes out our GPS
and we have so much dependent on it.
What are we going to do? We've got
people now worrying working on using
navigation by pulsars. Can't take those
out cuz those are cosmic. They're
sending highly timed pulses that reach
Earth in different places on the sky and
by measuring them you can and the time
delay between one and the other you can
actually localize yourself on our
surface with extremely high precision.
Okay, obviously we don't agree with Neil
when it comes to his denial of God and
all that stuff. But I'll be honest with
you, there were some comments that I saw
in the comments in the the podcast got
40 million views. I love the way he
teaches. There was one person who said
I've learned more about astronomy than
I've ever done in school, college and
university. I love the way he teaches
and I believe that we should definitely
benefit from that apart from his kufri
beliefs.
You know, in that sense he's absolutely
stupid. But when it comes to this
matter, I mean guys subhanallah and you
can see so they talk about the you know
the the Westerners talk about the
invention of you know Joseph Saxton
which and we give him credit etc. but
you know the credit goes back because
800 years before that something more
complex was designed by Mariam
al-Asturlabi. Joseph Saxton 1799-1873
was a prolific 19th century American
inventor and mechanist best known for
creating the early magneto-electric
machine and early dynamo in 19 in 1833,
the self-registering tide gauge and
several precision measuring instruments.
He also created the first known
photograph taken in Philadelphia in
1388. Well, you see it's very
interesting because they do not talk
about Mariam here. Subhanallah brothers
and sisters, there you go. And 800 years
before that Islam a Muslim woman
invented the astrolabe. Hope you guys
benefit from this inshallah brothers and
sisters. Till next time assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wabarakatuh. Give me your
comments inshallah in the comment
section below and if there is anything
else you would like me to look into when
it comes to Muslim invention, put in the
comments inshallah I can do my next
video about that. Till next time,
goodbye. Do not forget to subscribe,
like and share. Goodbye.